autre lieu autre discours il était la
véritable vedette de la fête de l'huma à
la courneuve une nouvelle fois jean luc
mélenchon s'est présenté comme le
candidat de la révolution citoyenne
écouter leader du front de gauche
ce monde nouveau qu'il faut faire naître
ce n'est pas un accord entre états
majors qui va le faire m c'est l'union
du peuple tout entier
c'est ce front du peuple qui commencera
à la nouvelle révolution française la
révolution citoyenne qui pour notre
chance puisque nous avons une élection
en 2012 peut commencer là où tout
commence pour un citoyen avec des
bulletins de vente dans des urnes
haut les coeurs ardents à la lutte tous
nous allons faire avancer une nouvelle
fois le fanal de combat qui rend la
france à son peuple comme ça